good morning John last week I went to my
first ever San Diego comic-con I was
there to do some panels by myself and
with some friends and also do a little
performance I had a lot of thoughts in
this place about how weird it is that I
get to be on the same stage as people I
consider super legitimately famous about
how we create tears of humanity and
place extra weight on being part of one
tear when in fact I can solidly confirm
that it is pretty identical to all the
other tears about how conventions like
this and the ones that I helped run surf
to concentrate the reality of fandom and
excitement and expression into the real
world and how great that is but while at
comic-con I had a more abstract thought
that hit me pretty hard there is so much
media now oh my god how do we consume it
all when I got back home from Comic Con
all my friends were talking about
stranger things and I was like but god
I'm still catching up on mr. robot I
haven't even seen the new Ghostbusters
movie yet there's so much music so many
books so many comics some of these shows
and movies and podcasts and YouTube
videos and we are all constantly
bombarded by voices telling us to eat
these things up real quick and as soon
as you're done move on to the next one
the media industry advertises on its own
media to push yet more media whether
that's reality TV sitcoms dramas or the
news never before has there been
anything like this much media but John I
got a secret for you the special thing
about comic-con
isn't the amount of media these people
consume it's the passion they have for
it and in a world where you nibble and
snack and then move on to the next thing
that passion which is the source of so
much joy in my life doesn't get
developed and so I asked myself what are
the shows the books the podcasts the
online communities that I spend more
time thinking about and contributing to
than consuming what are the pieces of
media that I go to over and over again
the albums that I can't stop listening
to the world's I read fanfic in because
I don't want to stop being inside of
them the books I can read for a fourth
time and still learn new things about
there aren't that many but I want there
to be more Jon outside of my hotel room
at Comic Con
there was a port for dole produce all of
the shipping containers came off a boat
and then they got stored and driven out
by semi trucks and since this is the
thoughts from places video you might
think I'm about to make some weird
abstract connection between the stuff I
was just talking about and this dull
shipping port but that's just too much
of a stretch it's just that I wanted to
show you this really cool time-lapse
that I made anyway I want to snack less
and have more good solid content meals I
want to stop consuming cheeto media and
focus on the things in this world that
make me love them that take up my brain
and make me think for weeks afterward
that make me love the world and
appreciate myself I want to love things
the way that these people love things
John I'll see you on Tuesday
hey if you want to love things like that
too I might suggest that you check out
nerdcon stories which is an amazing
opportunity to love great stuff I might
be a little bit biased because it is a
conference that I literally build with a
team of really great people but last
year it was just a fantastic time and
I'm very sad to say that I won't be able
to attend this year for reasons that
will become clear especially if you
listen to next week's dear Hank and John
or if you check out a very long video
that I just uploaded on Hanks channel so
I won't be there but John will and so
will a bunch of other amazing people
like John Scalzi Mary Robinette Kowal
Dylan Maron been a current Ben blacker
Cindy pon empty Anderson John darn
yellow the mountain goats
Desa darling Maureen Johnson Nell
Hopkins and Patrick Rothfuss pella but
see galooby a ton of other really great
people it's gonna be a wonderful time
I'm really sad that I can't be there but
I hope that you all have a great time
without me if you want to find out more
you can go to nerd Gong com